all right uh you saw that post on the
footwork
of this crazy ass stance okay so like
when I was in Chiba sensei's
organization that's right
but prior to that right I had done
many martial arts and those martial arts
always had a either a competitive aspect
to them or a self-defense aspect to them
and it was just there was no martial
advantage to standing on a tightrope
you just didn't ever do that it's very
easy to learn that
when someone's trying to kick your ass
um
you don't have balance
a weapon is completely behind
the front side for example
and then uh you're very slow out of the
stance in all eight directions because
of the way you bring tension and torque
into the joints which actually start
your initial angle of deviation your
ankle your knee and your hip
do you see that
I mean you could you could deviate
somewhat with your head and shoulders
but you're still on the line of attack
do you get it so your angle deviation
should always have your entire body
clear the line of attack and
when you are on a tightrope and you
bring that torque and tension into your
ankles knees and hips
a lot of those eight angles are just not
available to you very quickly
okay and so again through through a
process of elimination or Force
adaptation
you don't stand like that
in Parker Kenpo they named how you stand
they call it a neutral stance the
neutral stance means that you have equal
access to all of those eight different
directions so the eight different
directions are the directions you use in
Hubble Kitty
see and in East Asian culture Silk Road
culture those eight directions are
representative of the infinite
directions that you should be able to
move if you if you could do the eight
you can do the in infinite and so when
you're in this torque tension through
the ankles knees hips on a tightrope you
cannot do the eight and so
um you could think it all you want you
get it you can think I'd feel pretty
good here uh but you can't think it when
someone's punching you and kicking you
sweeping your leg taking you down do you
get it faking and fainting coming in
it's you
you realize I'm an idiot for thinking
this
okay
the
I don't think though you need to learn
through that kind of stress adaptation
environment I think you could just look
kinesiologically added biomechanically
and go
this I can feel the tension I can feel
the tension across my inner knee do you
see or I can feel the tension this puts
in my lower back
and anytime you have tension you have to
first uh
relax a muscle group in order to change
from where and how that muscle group had
you organized all the time right
right so like in shooting for example a
beginner always starts out like super
super tense right and you get really
good at shooting you realize that the
for example the nine millimeter round is
not going to send you flying backwards
it just doesn't have the the uh recoil
energy to do that to you so why is all
this tension there it's really from
anxiety uh and over time you learn just
to relax and as you relax uh you're much
quicker on Transitions and things like
that than if you were tense
in Destiny isn't that called legility or
something like that the three types of
weapons or characteristics you can have
you know what I'm talking about Joey's
like Mobility
yeah your your how fast your weapon is
what was that called
nah never mind there was something about
this weapon was faster moving through
them what is it handling handling okay
well it's the same thing and if you very
stiff your handling is going to be very
slow you can't transition between
targets very quickly so your top
shooters are pretty relaxed way more
relaxed than you would think
um
but it's the same thing right you guys
maybe as we do striking right if we're
doing any kind of live training with
your striking if you're tense you
Telegraph a lot more and you're just way
too slow right the dude's gone way
before you got there you have to be
relaxed uh as you're transitioning and
things like that
but you could also look at it
[Music]
um
you know as I said like culturally so
which sport
do you ever see this supposedly
tactically sound
posture you can there's nowhere there if
it was in any way biomechanically or
kinesiologically sound it would appear
somewhere in some other sport but it
just doesn't okay it's really unique
um
to only certain lineages okay
and as I said in the post if you go back
and you watch oh sensei's videos he's
never ended you can't find a video with
him in it except for one
that I saw him as an old man it was near
his death
and he kind of like throws somebody
normal in this dance and then all of a
sudden he goes
like it was the after thing you think
um
the fact that he didn't do the throw
like that the fact that he adopted it
after the throw the little stutter step
he kind of looked around looked at the
camera too right that mind is a that I
and the stuttering is the loss of the
god mind your inner fettered state do
you see that and see you're probably in
an intellectual state to me that speaks
it wasn't natural to him he's like maybe
he wanted to adopt it but it wasn't
natural to him because he hadn't
actually worked it dude just like when
you guys try something new your eyes go
all over the place and you stutter all
over the place
um
so I want to talk about well then how do
you stand and why do you stand the way
I'm going to tell you how to stand okay
and you have to understand
uh a few things
from a concentric point of view and
that's what we want to get to right now
okay so the first thing that I would say
remember when I talk about an a
concentric epistemy the analogy for
someone who doesn't know what concentric
means let alone a concentric epistemy is
think of Russian stacking dolls okay
little tiny
same image on the inside on the inside
on the inside on the inside okay
so you you would have let's say
an outside
or an external
and then you have an inside and and then
or an internal got it
and what happens on the outside
is consentive with what's happening on
the inside
okay and so you can't do something on
the outside that contradicts what's
going on on the inside
or everything falls apart okay so first
let's talk about what's going on on the
inside
okay
so
you're going to
take the young aspect
it's difficult for me today to say young
energy because when I say energy
you think like microwave or cell phone
or something I imagine those have young
aspects to them I'm more comfortable
with the young aspect and if you if you
want to identify it in inertia or
momentum or mass or something like okay
fine do you get it but it would be all
of those things okay plus gravity and
plus friction on the ground you see that
so your goal internals that we're going
to look at this and that's all we're
looking at right now
okay
is to take the young aspect
and internalize it
so for example if we have UK
and nuke is going to push on you
are you with me okay so this push that
UK is doing uh
finish this for me what do we call it
spinal displacement okay
so spinal displacement is the tactic
but spinal displacement is a young
tactic
okay all of your kihon waza in Aikido
assume spinal displacement
which tells you you guys know because
you know Jabs and you know all fakes and
feigns and you know measuring strikes
and all kinds of other tactics that
don't involve spinal displacement do you
get it and so you know if you try to do
inimage
on a jab
and it's not going to work do you see
there's a lot of Aikido people out there
though that are trying to do kihonawaza
for a jab
why because they have no other solution
to it all they know is kilon waza
it's no coincidence that they don't know
jab Cross or jab up or cat do you see or
jab hook
because if they did they would learn
real quick you can't do quotes again
do you understand okay
but yokio and Wasa assumes spinal
displacement spinal displacement is
a young aspect
and what you're supposed to do here's
your little body
is you internalize the young aspect
now you can do that because you're a
human being you're like why I don't know
why it's just what human beings can do
okay
you internalize the young aspect and
then you will Vector it down so it'll go
in your body
and it'll and then you Vector it down
okay and when it vectors down it's going
to hit the Earth and the Earth is going
to bounce it up
and those two forces are going to
generate your lower tonden
so when you look at kilo noaza and Uka
is prescribed to do spinal displacement
you ground Vector do you see you send
that energy down
it'll bounce back up and now the two of
you will have your lower tonden Fields
generated and you should feel that okay
when those two fields are simultaneously
generated by this internal process that
is kazushi
wherever I move as Naga my time dead
your time then will move okay even if I
want to hold it still
and you now want to move it you will
lose your balance do you see so that is
the seed of kazushi
all right
what you've done here is you have a
young aspect and then you have a Yin
aspect you see and together those meet
your time your lower tandem field they
make it they generate it
you do not have a Tom Den
like most Aikido people think it's two
inches below your navel and two inches
in from your skin you know you don't you
don't it's not an anatomical place
you see it's manifested only at this
time
do you understand that so one I would
need the skill in order to manifest it
in order to internalize young energy but
two I would have to be wanting to do it
at that time
okay otherwise it just it goes away the
two energies go away okay
all right
what you're supposed to do
with this field is spiral rotated
okay
so let me clean this up a little bit
here's your here's your dude
here's his legs
okay and then that field shows up in
here
and it's young energy going down and
your energy coming up
or really young energy transitioning do
you see into yin and Yin energy
transitioning into young okay
what you're supposed to do is spiral
rotate this thing
so I if this is a poor example because
your mind is gonna go it's like a ball
it's it's not a ball
it's not breath do you see like there's
air in here it's not air in there
um that's why I would your Energy's kind
of pushing it do you know because you're
gonna picture radio waves or something
do you understand do you get it
so but imagine
you had
you had energy going up do you see like
a line
got it
and what you're going to do is imagine
that at that point on this tandem field
was like right here
right here
okay but it's not a point remember I
already told you that it's a field
but we use this point for reference so
you can see what spiral rotation is okay
what you're going to do is you can
either go uh left
or you can go right doesn't matter okay
or you could go down or you could go up
initially
but the rule is that if you go to the
right
you can't come back left
do you get it so you and you also
have to go all the way around
so what is that Hemisphere and how many
degrees is that 180 you have to go 180
okay and add 180
you can't go all the way around you have
to go up or down
okay so let's say I want to go right
then I have to go down you see and now I
did the 180 again
and now can I can I continue no I can't
you see and I can't reverse it I now
have to take the other one do you see
that and then do the last one
okay
if you make this across
and you give these yin yang values what
you're doing is is spinning it rotating
it
and the cosmology would hold
that yin and yon now disappear because
they can never become oppositional to
each other
and they reconcile each other
do you understand
and this is now something else happens
when yin and yang cannot be oppositional
to each other they can they reconcile
each other and now yin and yang no
longer exists
do you get get that it's the
oppositional Theory okay now that yin
and yang no longer exists what exists
doubt
cow exist okay
so if my if my Tom Dan is doing a spiral
rotation on the inside of my body
I must do a spiral rotation on the
outside of my body
okay another words I cannot move
straight across the map
because my tandem would do that you know
my tongue then would do that I can't do
that I have to do this do you get it are
you with me okay because if I do that
you're going to have either Yin or young
get it okay
so my outers my outer shape must also
spiral rotate my kihonawaza must adopt a
spiral rotating architecture
okay
all right there's something else to note
here
and that's what makes the outside
concentric to the inside the inside at
the lower Tom Dan is forward rotating
outside my keyhorn architecture must
spiral rotate
okay
there's something else here and this
gives us the foot the foot problem okay
the foot problem
first when you have your feet like this
you will not be able to turn the front
hip into the final either in or down if
you're going for the front inward
kazushi or out or up
okay you won't be able to do it
but secondarily
aside from all that biomechanical stuff
that internalization of yawn
has to land on my midfoot
the midfoot is where it bounces back off
the ground
okay now why I don't know why it just
that's where it is okay you you can't
cry about the nature of the universe it
just did why is the sun coming up
tomorrow you're going to tell me how you
can't tell me why do you get that
okay
so same thing it has to be the midfoot
and when you adopt this posture
you will not be able to
internalize the young aspect send it
down to the midfoot you're going to send
it down to the heel or to the arch it's
too far back
okay it won't bounce back up
which is why
most people that adopt that are in a
bracing angle with the back leg to hold
positional integrity
versus ground vectoring I can take away
one leg and you still can't push me over
all those demonstrations okay
the other thing is
your your curvature
that you have in your body as this is
curving in
is done
with the qua
so the quad remember for simplicity's
sake it's your pelvis
oh you you have your torso here
are you with me okay
and this would be like your your belt
line or something your pubic line and
the claw is in the pelvic region okay
and your rotation
whatever rotation you get in your spiral
rotation externally is in the qua
meaning and we know this your qua only
has a limited degree of rotation
do you see my waist can go further do
you see that
we don't want to Pivot with our waist
because it externally presses
the lower Tom debt field like if I were
to
try to twist the two ends of this ball
I'm going to squeeze the middle out and
I don't want to do that
I want it to be pressured
expanding understand so you can't turn
your waist you can only turn your cloth
my waist never turns do you see that
well when your foot is pointed outward
on your front foot your claw can't
really turn
all right like this you see I cannot
turn the claw because the tension in the
knee is stopping it whereas if I turn my
front foot straight I get the quad back
do you see I don't have to turn my waist
quad turns
understood okay
so let's say what I said so far between
the concentric nature of what's
Happening inside of what's happening
outside I just discussed only the
energetic
whoa
[Music]
but the energetic is concentric
with the Tactical
if you violate the energetic
you're going to violate the Tactical
okay
when you get a spiraling rotating lower
tonden field and you use it in a spiral
rotating
quinoa's architecture for example
and most of your throws take and most of
your pins take someone's balance right
okay
what this spiral rotation does
is and let's go over the nature again
for balance okay so let's just say you
have this plane here
right and the center of gravity would be
here
and the line of gravity would fall
perpendicular to the Earth got it so
here's the Earth
okay the basis support would be the
parts that touch the Earth
and the area in between
understood
as long as the line of gravity is inside
of the basis support the person will
have balance
if I lean this thing so let's say I take
this plane and I start to tilt it up do
you see and make it tilt over
the line of gravity would be over here
and it would start to fall okay
what a spiral rotating architecture does
tactically
is it makes it impossible
for the attacker or the UK
to reposition their base of support
back under their line of gravity once I
start moving it outside of the basis
support okay now when you're fighting
someone they're always going to try to
regain their balance and when they try
to regain their balance they will always
do that by moving their basis support
back under the line of gravity that you
are manipulating
do you get it what your spiral rotating
architectures will do is that it will
take the line of gravity in One
Direction and the basis support in the
other direction making it impossible for
an adversary to regain their balance
okay
that's what we're going to look at now
oh
so if we're doing quote you home
okay
[Music]
inside
I'm moving my body obviously on this
rotation but inside my tandem
is going around
you see it's gonna go down
do you see that it's gonna come in up
and back out
got it
so maybe look look here don't look at
him and you'll see that I'm spinning
things
we'll do it again here I just turn
okay got it
now if you watch my movement
we're gonna go around
up and back
it is a spiral rotation as well
okay
if you look
and we go back to that cross
where I send his base of support One
Direction
and his line of gravity another
Direction this is what I tell you
you use the next pattern
okay
so
my edema is not going in the direction
that he's going
because my arm is on a different part of
the Spiral okay
my lady goes
this way
[Music]
so there's one vector
that way
on the other one
is going that way
okay
all on the spiral
watch me change it
this is very common
here
and I push back
you see do you get it
uh leave your feet where they are
leave your feet there
it worked
why
because he left his feet there and then
eventually the line of gravity gets
outside the base of support
that's what every choreographer you get
does
you get it
but nothing was stopping him from going
backwards so as you start to lose your
balance
push your base and support back under
your line of gravity
you see that
try it again
[Music]
cannot do it do you understand
so internally I'm working it
energetically externally same things
happen on the outside and tactically
those things help me stop him from
putting his faces forth back under his
line of gravity then he falls okay
so
if you look
me
I can't eat Amy like this
you see
I have to if you may
this way
you see
I can't go here
no because I'm not throwing in the same
direction he is I'm throwing across the
direction he's going
so my foot
is going to be
in
do you see and the qua
finishes it ever so it's like boom boom
boom
got it
so start looking for that
foreign
[Music]
spiral you see and then you're using the
back outward position this one you see
okay
but the movement is the same so my foot
is slightly in and then the claw does
the throat the quad does the throat okay
even though it's going this way it's
like this
it's not like this
okay and it's not pushing the guy and
it's not pushing the guy
right
so if we're uh
I'm gonna do it again
you see
and if you look at his body
right
this is gonna look like the back outward
again
[Music]
but it's gonna be the back inward
because
and again if he's going that way take
your X again
his head's going that way
then his base
going that way
okay
and so I can't
enter like this
I'm going to put my hip
right on his hip
and project on the clock
is this a thing
step two
[Music]
foreign
but to me it's not a horse dance
because the horse dance his feet
slightly in you see and 50 50 weight
distribution
this foot
think straight slightly in and this foot
is clearly not
doing the same thing over here okay and
this brings up an important part on the
back foot
your foot must be oriented
in the direction you're going
it cannot be straight however
because now it's working against the
front claw
okay
and the widest it could be
is 90 degree to the angle attack
if it opens up more
weights on the heel now I'm on my heels
now
okay so what's the max it can go
90 to the line of attack
if you watch me I tend to be shy of the
90. okay so watch the back foot now
and watch how weight will shift to the
front foot out of the 50 50 weight
distribution the womb
front foot is heaven front foot is heavy
too much
foreign
[Music]
that he leaves his feet still and he
goes he does his false boom not what I'm
doing
rotate
okay so everything's there still a gay
try
in him
so this time I'm on the front inward
not the back inward the front inward but
it's going to be exactly the same this
is Ezekiel so I'm going to take his line
of gravity this way
but his basic support is going this way
same thing if I do the way people do
ikyo leave your feet there
it works
run your feet forward knocking over it
you have to cut his stance off
which is designed in this technique cut
his stance off
[Music]
same thing it's moving
moving
full moving incomplete
all right let's try it hey this is for
you Dashi here I I don't have to push
this down
to lower his elbow
he's falling
the elbow is going to lower I just stay
up with it okay so I'm not pushing his
elbow
[Music]
you attack the base base boom I stay up
not here
[Music]
back to base triangle step
boom
stay up with it
which you can do with this footwork
do the other one
again if he wants to resist
[Music]
I'm never gonna get that
okay
you need the spiral try it